Joy is a great teacher who has
created many amazing courses
and written a bunch of helpful
technical articles. In this course,
He will teach you how a sink await
and promises work in JavaScript.
Hey guys, you're here in this video, we're gonna
make ice cream and learn Asynchronous JavaScript.
Yes, you heard me right, we're gonna
make ice cream today. And along the way,
we're going to discuss three topics, callbacks,
promises, async await along with examples,
the video will go like this over here, we're going
to make the main project, which is the ice cream
project. And over here, we're going to look at
some examples so that you can better understand
how the system works. But the first question
is, what is Asynchronous JavaScript? And why
should you even care? If you want to make bigger
projects more efficiently, then this is for you.
What Asynchronous JavaScript does is it allows you
to break down bigger projects into smaller tasks.
And then using any of these three methods over
here, either callbacks, promises or async await,
what you can do is you can form a
connection between these small steps
in a way that you can get the final result. So
here's an example of what I mean. So this is the
ice cream that we're gonna make today. Here's the
ice cream. Okay, so using Asynchronous JavaScript,
we can break it down into smaller steps. If we
do that, it looks something like this, you can
see that these are the seven steps to make ice
cream first, starting with the Place Order, then
we're going to cut the fruit, then we're going
to add water and ice, so on and so forth. And at
the very last, we're going to serve ice cream. To
make you understand this topic even better, I have
added some time function as well. You can see this
over here, it takes two seconds to place the order
two seconds to cut the fruit one second to add
water and ice, so on and so forth. And at the
very last we're gonna serve ice cream, take the
money and buy ourselves a Lambo, because why not?
If you want to learn Asynchronous JavaScript
better and know the difference between two things,
synchronous and asynchronous system, let's
start discussing with the synchronous system.
Let me explain this to you in clear words. Let's
say that I have given you 10 tasks and just one
hand 10 task one hand, so how will you do the
task? You are going to do one by one, right? Like
this look, 123. So we are in tax number three,
right? You cannot jump to the tax number seven
unless you do 456. And then seven. Right. So what
are you doing? You're doing one by one, right.
But in the asynchronous system for 10 task,
you will be given 10 hands so that you can work
independently without depending on anyone. Look
at this image over here. This is a synchronous
system, they are loading one by one, the second
image doesn't load unless the first one does.
And the third image doesn't load unless the
second one does, which means that they're
following a order like this 123. And on the
asynchronous way, you can see that nobody
depends on anyone they are loading on their own
pace independently. By the way, I wrote an entire
article on the topic that we're going to discuss
today so that you can understand it better.
At the same time, you can revise it from
here more easily, efficiently and quickly.
Link of this article will be given in the
description down below, go and check it out.
To summarize, let's say that we're setting up
a marathon for three persons, how many person
three person, if you are doing it in the
synchronous way, what will happen is you just have
one single lane, and you have to place those three
persons on this single lane in this area of 123.
And the rule is nobody can overtake the other,
everyone has to finish the race one by one. Look
at this image over here. This is the synchronous
system. This is the finish line over here. Okay,
and the images, which is the person's One, two
and three are standing on the same lane, which
lane same lane and nobody can overtake the other,
everyone has to finish the race one by one. So the
person three or the image three will finish the
race first, then the second one and the first one
like this, the single lane, the synchronous
system. If anyone stops, the entire process stops.
If the image three stops over here that everyone
has to stop. And if we are setting the marathon in
an asynchronous way, for three persons, we will
have three lanes. If we have more participants,
then the number of lanes will also increase,
which means that nobody stops for anyone, they can
finish the race independently on their own pace.
If anyone stops, then the system still continues
to run. Look at this image over here. This is
the finish line and this is the participants
over here and these are the lanes Okay, lane
number one, two, and three, the image one, two,
and three. They're gonna finish the race on their
own pace. I hope you understand the difference
between the synchronous and asynchronous system.
Let's look at some examples right now. You can use
any code editor you want but for this tutorial,
I'm going to write Don't go pen because it has
a simple interface. So you can follow along
with me if you want. So open code pen.io. And
then you click this pen over here, then you're
going to click this small pen icon over here,
and you're going to name this project, anything
you want, I'm going to write it async j s.
Okay, and then you save it Ctrl F, like this Ctrl
S. And now you're going to drag it in the middle,
like this, and double click on the JavaScript
section like this, and it's going to expand.
And in order to open the console, you're
going to click this small icon over here,
you can see that like this, double click on here,
and it's going to expand like this, we need to
know we need to do one more setting, you come over
here, this small gear icon over here, click it,
click on behavior, and you enable everything
except this one, the auto updating preview. Okay,
turn it off, Save and Close. And then we're
going to manually get a run button over here.
Why is that? That's because every time we write
a single letter, corporate runs it automatically,
which means that every time we write a single
letter, we're going to get an error after error
after error. In order to avoid that I have turned
off this setting. Every time we finished writing
our code, we can manually run it like this. Okay,
now let's look at the synchronous system example.
So we're here we write synchronous si nc HRONOS
synchronous like this. And you comment this like
this. And over here, we're going to write console
dot log five times how many times five times like
this following console dot log, okay, brackets,
double quotes space over here, okay, you copy this
Ctrl C, and then Ctrl, v 510s. Okay, 345. It's
some gap over here as well, additional gaps,
like this. Alright, so over here, we're going
to write a full sentence. Okay, I eat ice cream
with a spoon. So again, divided by phrases, okay,
then follow me along. I eat ice cream. With sorry.
Spoon, okay, Ctrl S to save it. And then
you're going to click this run over here.
And then we're going to get the result,
there we go, you can see that our phrases
are printed one by one serial. That's because
JavaScript runs from the top to the bottom,
how does JavaScript run from the top to the bottom
serially? In this process, if anyone gets stuck,
then the entire process get stuck. This is the
synchronous system. If you change the sale,
let's say that I want to change the spoon from
here to here, okay, Ctrl x, and then you paste
it over here, Control V Control F, you clear this
console over here, and then you run it again,
let's see what Let's see the result. Now you can
see that I eat spoon ice cream with a you see
the JavaScript doesn't care about anything is
gonna run the code from the top to the bottom.
This is what the synchronous system. Now
let's look at the asynchronous system.
Now over here, right, asynchronous, okay, a
synchronous done, clear the console over here, you
change the CL Ctrl x. Okay. And we're here Ctrl
V Ctrl S. And now come over here at the bottom, I
need to make you understand a small function named
set timeout function, which is a built in function
of JavaScript. What this does is it allows you
to run a function after a specific amount of
time. So you write set timeout set, then capital
letter T, timeout, this one, okay, then brackets,
the first thing that we are going to
pass as an argument is a function. So
we're going to use the arrow function, don't
worry, I'm going to explain arrow function
and the regular function with the arrow function
like this, okay, equal to this sign curly braces.
Now let's look at the difference between function
the regular one and the arrow function. Okay,
in the regular way, we write a function like
this first, the function keyword, okay, then
we're going to name it like this A, B, C, D, E,
F, G, however you like, right? Then you put that
then you put that bracket like this, okay? And
then curly braces, this is the regular function,
but in the error function, how we write it is
we're going to write either late var or const.
Okay, like this. And then we're gonna put the name
over here. What was the name of this function? A,
B, C, D, D, right? So we're gonna write ABCDE
D, which is the name of that funk. Like this,
like this, and that equals, and then we're gonna
put brackets over here and then this sign over
here, the arrow sign, and then curly braces. On a
regular function, we used to put our arguments on
this bracket like a, b, c, d, etc. In the arrow
function, we place our arguments over here, A,
B, sorry, D, C, D, etc. I hope you understood the
difference between two for this project, I'm going
to use an arrow function. Okay, the latter one,
this one. So once we have entered the function
inside the set timeout as an argument, the next
thing that we're going to put is the time, okay,
so it is actually counted as milliseconds. If
we write 1000 is going to count as millisecond,
which means one second. So if we write, let's say,
3000, it means 3000 milliseconds, which is three
seconds. Okay? Now come over here. Let's say that
I want to cut this and place it inside this set
timeout function. How will you do it? We'll cut
it like this Ctrl x. And that insight over here,
this curly braces, we're going to place it over
here, okay. Ctrl V. And now let's change it to
four seconds. By the way, it said timeout is a
asynchronous function, okay. You got this from
here, Ctrl x, and you paste it over here. Ctrl
V, like this Ctrl S to save it. And then we're
going to press this run function. But before that,
do you remember what I told you? JavaScript runs
from the top to the bottom how from the top to
the bottom. And let's see how this works. Okay,
run it like this. And let's see the result.
Now you can see that we have got, I eat with
a spoon. And then after how many seconds after
four seconds, we got the ice cream over here.
Now how does this system work? This is an
asynchronous system. Okay, asynchronous system.
Look, the cereal is over here. Okay, I eat ice
cream with a spoon. The sale is over here as well,
you can see that I eat ice cream with it spoon.
The system is actually working like this Look,
I eat and then this ice cream over here it
has a set time of function, which means that
we're going to have another hand over here
is going to take this function at the side,
which is our second lane. Okay, this
is our main lane. I mean main road,
this is the secondary road, it is taking that
asynchronous call at this hand. And after four
seconds is going to release it on our main lane
like this. Until then what will happen Look, I
eat ice cream is an asynchronous call, which
means that is going to take it over here,
after four seconds is going to get released, then
with a spoon after four seconds is going to come
over here. So this is how the asynchronous
system works. I hope you understood it.
Now we're going to start our discussion with
callbacks. But before that, if you're new to
the channel, feel free to subscribe because I
post videos based on practical work projects
so that you can level up your coding skills. If
that sounds interesting, hit the subscribe button
and join my gang under the further ado, let's
get started. Let's talk about callbacks. What are
they? In simple terms, very simple terms. calling
a function inside another function is called a
callback. In even more simple terms, what it does
is it forms a connection between what functions.
Let's look at one example with callbacks. And
then we're going to start our ice cream business.
Again, back to code pen. you delete
everything okay? Ctrl A, then delete. Okay,
you clear the console over here as well. Ctrl
S. Okay. So what did they tell you before
callbacks means calling a function inside another
function. So we'll create two functions to form
the relationship. What relationship Okay, function
one, function two, like this. function, one, okay.
We're going to use a regular function. Nothing
complicated. No politics here. Okay. Function
two. Okay, now inside function one, what we're
going to write is console dot log, okay, console
dot log. Over here, we're going to write function
one, or let's write step one. Okay, step one,
of sorry, like this step one. In fact, we're here
we're going to write console dot log, step two,
like this, in order to run this
function, what do we do we write
the name of the function at the bottom like this
look. We call it like this one, then brackets over
here. Control As you run this button over
here, after you clear the console, okay,
run it like this. And we're going to see step one
on the console. Let's wait, there we go. This is
step one. Okay? And how do we call the function
two in the same process, we write it over here.
I mean, we call it over here like this, okay? Ctrl
F. Don't forget to clear the console over here,
create like this, and then you paste this run
button. Now you can see that we have step one,
step two, that's because we have an order, right?
JavaScript runs from the top to the bottom.
Look which one is first one is first,
and then to what if we reverse the order
before I do first and then one like this Ctrl x
Ctrl V like this. So first is two and then one.
So what will happen to will run first
and then one, clear the console. Save it,
run it, you can see that we have step two first.
And then step one, these are regular functions.
Now let's form a relationship between these
two using a callback what a callback. Okay?
Let's remove this. Okay. Now we're going
to make a connection of function to
inside function one. So how do we do it, we do
it easy a argument, we're gonna write over here
called to see a double L, hyphen, okay? This
is nothing, this is just an argument, okay?
Nothing else. And over here, we're going to write
step one complete. Okay? This is nothing special,
this is just gonna get printed on our console.
Okay? Please call step two, like this. Okay. Oh,
like this. Now, in order to provoke function to
what we do is, we take this argument over here,
called
to, and then, as number two function is
a function, what we're going to write
is we're going to give brackets over here
like this. And now it's going to call it
every time. Once our console dot log is
printed like this, look, we don't have
to call to anymore, we just call one, one.
And then inside over here, we're gonna pass
function number two, which one function number
two, okay, to like this, look, how do they form
a relationship between these two? If you clear the
console, save it, run it, let's see the result.
Look what is happening, step one, complete, please
call step two. And then we have the step two.
If you remember, JavaScript runs from the top
to the bottom, right. So our console dot log is
at the first and then call to, but if you
reverse the order, what will happen? Let's see.
Ctrl x, okay. Call it over here, Control V,
Control S. Okay, and now clear the console,
run it and let's see what happens. Now you can see
that step two is first and then step one complete
place called step two. Don't worry about this.
If you don't understand it, we're going to look
at another example right now. For that we're
gonna start our ice cream business right now.
For that we need to know the relationship
between our customers and us. You can see
that this is the flow Okay, first we get the
order from the customers, then we're going to
fish the ingredients. Then we're going to start
the production and then we're going to serve
ice cream. Okay, so we're going to create two
functions, how many functions two functions, order
function, production function, okay? If we don't
get the order, we cannot start the production.
This is how we're forming a connection between
these two functions using what Tell me using
a callback. Come on. Let's go to corporate and
see the example. Come over to copan over here,
you delete everything. Okay, we're going to use
arrow function what function arrow function,
right lead, first is order because without the
order, the production doesn't start okay. Order
equal to brackets, then arrow
sign curly braces like this. Okay,
now write the production function, but before
that clear this console, okay? Let production
duction here we're going to make the ice
cream. Okay. So once we get the order, we're
going to start the production of ice cream, okay.
Production equal to brackets, arrow sign curly
braces like this. Okay? Now in order to form that
connection, that every time we get the order, the
production will start. We do it like this. Okay,
you come over here. Okay, you pass an argument.
We're going to name it call production,
okay. Call underscore, pro dot tion, okay.
And inside these curly braces, we're going to
write the same thing. Okay, the exact same name
Ctrl C Ctrl, V over here and then brackets
Okay, brackets like this. And look at there.
We have formed a relationship between these two
functions is it what a callback now let's test
it. Now we're going to write console dot
log, console dot log, okay? order placed,
please call production like
this, okay. And inside over here,
we're going to write console dot log console
dot log order received. Starting broad duction.
Like this, okay. Now in order to run our
function, what we'll do is, we're gonna
write order over here or there, and inside that
order, we're going to write the production.
We're going to pass this function over
here inside here, okay, bro. duction,
like this. Okay, so Ctrl F, clear the console,
save it, run it. Let's see what happens.
Now, you can see that we have order placed, please
call production. And then we got order received,
start production. I hope you understand how the
system works, or forming relationship between
functions using a callback. Now let's understand
one more thing, the relationship between the
front end and the back end. The front end is
our kitchen where we will make the ice cream
and the back end is where we'll store ingredients
like fruits, liquid stuffs, missionaries,
raw materials, chocolate, etc. You know what raw
materials means, right? The stocks, our stocks,
the stocks is a back end kitchen is the front end,
okay? So we're going to store our stocks inside a
variable, okay, so come over to code pen over here
at the very top, okay. Keep some space over here.
And we're going to write let Okay, net stocks.
So this variable will hold all of our stocks,
like fruits, liquids, holders, toppings like
chocolate, peanuts, etc. Okay, and that's equal
to we're going to create a object over here
like this object, okay? And inside the object,
we're going to write arrays like this look,
f are you IDs Okay, then colon over here,
we're going to store all our foods
inside what an array Okay, like this.
Then we're going to write the name of our
fruits. As I have defined them over here,
I'm going to copy it over here. Okay. Ctrl C, and
then Ctrl V over here. Now pause the video, take a
moment to write these foods. Okay. Now how do we
access a single stock from this variable? Okay,
we comment everything from here from top to bottom
like this, comment this like this. And in order to
select one stock, we'll do it like this. First
of all, we write the name of the variable What
is the name of the variable stocks Okay, sto ck s
then dot y dot because it is an object in order to
access the object we need to form a dot and then
the name of the object is which is fruits, okay,
capital letter F r u IDs. And then what is this,
this is an array. So how does the array works is
it is arranged in the order of 012 and three,
okay? So you know, x is that you right,
square bracket, okay, and then if we want to
access the banana, let's look at the order 012,
we write two over here. Okay, and now let's print
on the console. In order to do that you write
console, dot log, then bracket at the end bracket,
close it, Ctrl S, clear it, and then run it.
Look, we got the banana. In the same way we have
more stocks, we have the holders, the cups, cone
sticks, and the toppings as chocolate sprinkles.
So this is the variable that I have created. Okay,
I'm going to copy it from here Ctrl C. And
then over here, I'm going to paste it Ctrl V.
Now pause the video, take a moment and
write this talk on your code editor.
So once that's done, you clear this from
here. Okay, clear the console and you bring
all of this back, okay, like this. There we go.
Okay, now we're going to clean our console from
here remove this and we're going to remove this
Okay, and keep everything else and then you come
in this form here, okay? Now Now the first thing
is the order right customer places the order
the order is changeable, which means how many
options do we have? Look at our menu, we have the
strawberry, grapes, banana, and Apple which means
that the customer can pick anything he wishes,
which means that for this we need a variable.
So over here we're going to write fruit, name
f Are you it? Okay, underscore and me
like this 10th place Come over here.
So we have two arguments, the fruit name and the
call production, the Customer Picks the fruit,
it gets over here. And then we get to
know that what the customer picked.
And then we're going to start the production.
This is how we're forming a relationship between
our functions. Okay. And over here, you uncomment
this, and we need to keep it blank for now. Okay,
you give double quotes over here, then comma,
okay, it's Ctrl S, if you remember, this is
our steps along with a time. So in order to ensure
the time function, we're going to use set timeout.
And we're going to print the steps on our console.
Okay, so follow along with me. First of all,
we're going to place the order by picking a fruit
name, Okay, come back to VS code over here. And,
and in order to select the fruit and place the
order, it takes two seconds, how many seconds,
two seconds. So come back to VS code over here
and inside this order function. Okay, come
here and write console or before granting
console dot log, you have to use a set
timeout function because it takes how many
seconds, two seconds, set timeout like this.
And inside over here, we're going to use an arrow
function. You can also use an anonymous function
like this look, function bracket curly braces
like this, but we're going to keep it simple.
We remove this, remove this function from here,
and you're going to give that arrow sign like
this, okay? And at the end, we're going to place
the time function, okay, how many seconds, two
seconds. So we're gonna write 2000 milliseconds,
okay. 2123, like this. And inside over here,
we're going to write console dot log, because
we're going to, because we're going to print the
result on our console. Okay, and use a backtick.
We're not going to use double quote, no, no,
we're not using double quotes, we're going to use
a backtick. What backtick if you want to access
the backtick, look at my keyboard over here. This
is the exit key. And this is the key to write
backticks. Okay, so you click this just once, and
it is going to print us two backticks like this.
Now, we're going to pause this fruit name inside
this console dot log. So how do we do this? First
of all, we're going to write $1 sign, okay, what
$1 sign, dollar sign and then curly braces like
this. And then we're going to place this inside
here, but before that, we need to write something.
We need to write the stocks. Okay? There's because
we're picking it for stocks, right? So stocks,
then the name of our fruits, okay,
so dot F r q IDs, and then what?
square brackets right square brackets over
here, and then we're going to pass this
inside there, okay? Ctrl C, Ctrl, C, and
then write Control V over here. Okay,
now we're going to save it. Let me show you
how the system works. Okay, so over here,
we're going to write zero Ctrl F to the console,
run it, let's see, what do we get on the result?
We got strawberry, you can see that the first
fruit on our stock is a strawberry right? I
explained this to you right, if you can recall how
to access the stocks, we do it like this stocks
dot F r u it s then square brackets and then the
name of our food, I mean the order of I mean the
order of the food 0123 right. So I have placed
this inside over here. And then inside the array,
I have placed this and over here I have placed
zero which means that this zero is coming over
here, which eventually means that we are going to
get the strawberry, I hope you understood this.
Nothing complicated. Okay, stocks dot fruits,
then this and over here you write was selected
like this, then Ctrl F, clear the console, run it.
Let's see what we get. Strawberry was selected,
you can see that you're gonna notice that we got
the result after two seconds. Why is that? That's
because we are using a set timeout function
over here, which takes two seconds. I mean
it I mean it prints a result after two seconds.
Okay, let's start writing inside our production
function. Okay, so come over here, we're going
to use another set timeout function which
runs in zero seconds. How do you do it? We do it
like this right set timeout, bracket and plus a
function over here like this arrow function, okay.
And that is going to run in zero seconds, how many
seconds? zero seconds. So right 0000. Instead,
over here, we're going to write console dot log.
And write production has started. And that is
because we got the order right production have
started Ctrl S to clear the console. Let's run
it. So we're going to get the result after two
seconds, one, two. There we go, we have the
production has started and then strawberry was
selected. Now we are seeing a or behavior over
here. Why is that we were supposed to get this
one first and the production has started at the
last. That's because if you focus over here,
you can see that look at the order, okay,
JavaScript runs from the top to the bottom. Okay,
so it is saying that this is a set timeout
function, which means that it's going to take
two seconds and this one, this is going to take
how many seconds, zero seconds, Okay, this one
will be stopped, this is over here. And this coal
production will start immediately. So this is
the coal production, which is production has
started over here, and strawberry was selected,
this is over here. That's why we're getting
this order. But if you want to fix that,
what you have to do is you're going to cut it
from here Ctrl x, and you're going to place
it where inside that set timeout function.
Okay, like this look Ctrl V over here, okay.
Now what will happen is, it's not going to start
the production unless the fruit was selected.
Now let's save it, clear the console
and run it and let's see what happens.
One, two. So you can see that after two seconds,
strawberry was selected, and immediately we got
the result production has started there is because
we have said two seconds for which one strawberry
was selected and zero seconds for which one
production has started like this. I hope you
understood so far. Now let's look at our second
step, which is we're going to cut the fruit and
it will take two seconds. So come inside the
production function, we are done with our order
function, okay, you can minimize it like this. We
don't need it anymore. And don't make that mistake
again. Otherwise, you're going to get the reverse
order, which we watch previously, which is we got
the production first and the strawberry at the
last. Don't write it outside, okay. Don't write
it over here. You're going to write it inside this
set timeout function. Okay. So you come over here,
and we're going to write another set timeout.
Okay, it's gonna be two seconds, how many
two seconds, set timeout, okay, brackets, and then
pass a arrow function like this. Okay, arrow sign,
curly braces, and then the time function, okay,
how many seconds, two seconds. 2123, like this.
And inside over here, we're going to write the
food has been chopped console, the log. Das fruit
has been shot Ctrl F, the let's clear the console.
Save it. Let's run it and see what happens. One,
two. Again, one, two. So we're getting the
strawberry after two seconds. We have got
the production immediately. And then we have got
the fruit has been shoved after another additional
two seconds. Now our system is running perfectly
fine. Now let's follow the steps and complete our
ice cream production so that we can buy ourselves
a Lambo because why not? Now the third step is
to add water and it takes one second how many one
seconds. So inside the production function, where
will we write, we're going to write it inside
this set timeout function. So this is the parent
children, it will be the grandchildren.
Okay, so the food has been chopped over here.
Enter to give some spacings and you're gonna
write set timeout like this, okay, brackets,
then pause the arrow function like this equal to
Okay, clearly basis. Don't worry, I know where
we're going. We're going to a callback hell,
his collar callback hell, and I'm coming to
the point don't wait, don't, don't panic, okay.
And over here, you write the time function, okay?
1000 seconds over here like this. Okay, and
inside over here, console dot log like this.
Okay, inside over here, we're not going to write
double quotes, we're going to write backticks.
That's because we have to add water and ice and
the water and ice inside our stocks over here,
which is the liquid and then water ice zero and
one in order to pick them. Pay close attention
to what I write over here. Okay? Don't focus on
anything else. 123 This is the third step. Okay,
inside over here. backticks What backticks like
this dollar sign, and then curly braces, okay,
curly braces like this, any right end over here,
okay, and then curly braces, again like this.
Along with the dollar sign. Okay, you're
going to, you're going to write was added.
So, if you translate, it sounds like this dash
and dash was added. So we're going to write
So we're going to pick the water and ice. So first
of all, you're going to write stocks. Okay? stocks
dot liquid, okay? As because it is the
name of that object, liquid and then
square brackets like this. Over here
you're going to write zero. Okay,
that's because it will select the water. The
first thing is the water and then we have the ice
in order to pick that ice over here, okay,
we're going to write stocks, dot liquid.
Okay, then square brackets, we're gonna write one
and it will pick the ice like this, okay? Ctrl F.
And then we have also set it to one second.
Okay, so we're going to get it after one second,
clear the console. Save it right, let's count one,
two, again, 121. Now we can see that we got this
after two seconds, we got this immediately, we got
it after two seconds, and an additional one second
later, we got water and ice was added, which
means that our function is running properly.
Now we're gonna start the machine, it will take
one second, okay? Inside this, okay, stocks,
dot liquid, I mean, where we have selected
the water and ice, okay, so inside over here,
we're going to write set timeout. Okay, good.
Then the arrow function over here, curly braces.
And over here we're going to write what the
time function okay? 1000 seconds like this.
And inside here, we're going to write console dot
log. And then we're going to write the machine
was started. Let's write the machine
has been started. Made the machine has
been, let's write the machine was started.
Okay, Ctrl S, let's complete all of our
steps and then run it together. Okay. The next
step is we need to select the container. Okay.
Now, if we come over to the stocks,
you can see that on the holder object,
we have a lot of options. We have the cone,
the cup and the stick. Let's pick the cup.
No, I changed my mind. Let's pick the cone. Okay.
In order to do that, you can go here, okay, where
the machine was started, okay. And at the bottom
over here, we're going to write the set timeout.
So the cup takes two seconds, okay. So you're
going to write set, timeout like this, okay?
Give some space. Otherwise, you're going to
get confused by yourself. Okay, set timeout,
and then brackets. Then over here, you're
going to give that arrow sign, I mean,
the arrow function and then you're going to set it
up. Sorry, the time over here. Okay, two seconds.
And then you said over here, I'm going to
write console dot log, we have pick which
one? The code right, let's see that where is the
code? holder? Okay. Stocks dot holder dot zero.
Okay, let's write it over here. Okay, don't get
confused. It is over here below the machine. Okay,
we're going to give what backticks that's
because we're trying to get something
outside the function. Okay, so dollar sign
curly braces, stocks strc Ks stocks dot which
one was that holder? It's your LD. That's
because this is the holder over here. Okay.
Stocks dot holder and then zero. Let's come
back over here. Then we're going to give
square brackets like this and then we're going
to write zero over here and then we're done.
What's the next step? The next step is we're
going to select the topping ah my favorite
I love chocolates whatever you comment down
below Do you like waffles chocolates or peanuts?
Okay then um where was I? Oh yes, we're going to
select what chocolates okay as the toppings look
stocks dot toppings we have that so don't forget
that Okay, and then we're going to pick the zero
You can also pick peanuts also as well. In order
to pick that peanut you're going to write one okay
stocks dot toppings dot one okay. Over here okay.
This is the holder Oh, I forgot to write okay.
Which means that the cup was I mean
the cone was selected. Again selected.
Or you can also write ice cream was placed on the
cone. Okay, come over here and write ice cream
was placed on what the ice cream was placed on
this one which means on the cold ice cream was
placed on go. Alright, so inside over here,
give some spacings and we're going to pick
what the topping it takes three seconds because
we need some time to make The chocolate right?
So we're here right? set timeout, okay, exact
date and arrow function like this and then it's
going to take three or sorry, three seconds. Okay.
So what are we going to do? We're going to pick
toppings. So console, log like this
and backticks Okay, don't forget that
backticks like this. dollar sign, curly braces
and what we're going to write stocks, stocks dot
toppings, we have the S at the last toppings and
then this square brackets, then write 01 through
s. And what's the last step? We're going to serve
the ice cream okay. So in order to serve the ice
cream come over here, okay, where we have written
this Oh, this is just plain chocolate. I forgot
to write more text okay. So stocks dot toppings,
which is a chocolate was added okay? As toppings
like this, okay. And over here, give some spacing,
right, another set timeout function. Okay,
set timeout. And over here. We're going
to place an arrow function like this.
And then we're going to set the time which takes
how many seconds to serve two seconds, okay. 2123
console dot log. Then double
quotes. Serve. Ice cream
Ctrl S, okay, now clear the console over here.
Now run the code. Let's see what happens. Okay,
strawberry was selected production has started
fruit has been chopped water and ice added the
machine was started, ice cream was placed on cone
chocolate was added as toppings. Then we're gonna
serve the ice cream. Then we're going to take the
money and buy ourselves a Lambo. Yay, party. Okay,
now we have completed our process, the callbacks.
But look at look at this, what have we created?
Let me expand this and let me show you what
we have created. It is called a callback hell.
Look at here Look. Look at this format of how it
is going. Okay, look, look look look like this.
And then it is indeed like this. This is called a
callback hell, what is it called? callback hell.
Let me show you the format. The callback hell
looks something like this. Look at this format
over here. And look at our code over here.
It looks similar. It looks like this. Look,
it looks like a Christmas tree. You can also call
it the Christmas tree of hell. Because why not?
I know I know. I know that callbacks
are very confusing. And it is a hell.
So what's the solution of callbacks, we have
promises and promises looks like this. Look.
This is the promises It looks very clean. Very
neat. So let's compare again, this is our callback
hell. And this is our promises. Look how clean it
looks. The thing works like this callbacks make
relationships, parent children, grandchildren,
grand grandchildren, grand grand grandchildren,
grand grand grand grandchildren, it was
relationship like this. So what what what
promises do is it takes instructions like this,
first do this, then this, then this, then this,
then then then then then it works like this. Which
means that you can keep your code very neat and
clean. So far, so good. Let's start discussing
our promises. In order to understand the promise,
first of all, you need to understand the promise
cycle. So this is the diagram I made about
the promise cycle. First of all, a promise is
made, what promise do we make to our customers,
sir, we promise that we're gonna serve you
ice cream, what ice cream, we promise we're
going to serve you ice cream. So there are two
parts of this promise, either a truly fulfilled
or it will get rejected. Okay, so here, first of
all, it comes to this stage, the pending stage,
every customer when they come into our shop, we
promise we're gonna serve you ice cream. So our
customer interests, our shop sits on the table
looks at the menu, and he or she didn't order
anything. He's there sitting over there. This
stage is called the painting stage. He didn't
order anything just sitting over there. So this
is the pending stage, nothing is happening.
We then take the order, we didn't start the
production. Okay. And now let's say that
the customer has placed an order he wants mango
ice cream. If we have the mango on our stock,
then we can go to the next stage, which is we can
resolve the promise, which means that we can serve
ice cream to our customer. But if we don't have
the mango, then what will happen is we have to
reject him by saying Sir, we don't have mango at
our stocks. We're very sorry. So let's say that
we have mango on our stocks, what will happen
is, is going to get resolved, first of all,
and then after that, what will happen is we have
seven steps to make ice cream, right? Yes or No,
we have seven steps to make ice cream, and it
will follow like this, first of all do this,
then this, then this, then this, like this
intro, there are seven dents or six dents,
depending on the circumstances, depending on the
situation, don't worry, we're gonna write code
and see how this thing works. Once that's
done, we can serve ice cream to our customers.
But let's say that we didn't
have mango, what will happen is,
we have to pass through this reject stage. And
then over here on this catch, we're gonna write a
sorry, note, we're gonna say, sir, we're
very sorry, we don't have this on our stock.
We sincerely apologize for the inconvenience.
And once either we get resolved,
either our promise gets resolved or rejected, this
finally will always run, let's say that we serve
zero customers. At the end of the day, we have to
close our shutters. I mean, we have to close our
shop. But let's say that at the end of the
day, we serve 100 customers, 100 customers,
we still have to close our shop, right? Because
the employees has to leave, we have to leave.
This is the finally handler, don't worry,
we're going to discuss all of them in details.
Once you have understood this promise cycle, we
need to understand for more things, don't worry,
this is very short. First of all, we need to
understand the relationship between two things,
time and work, what time and work. Because
we have this list over here, you can see
that first of all, we have the work and then
the time. That's why those two relationships.
The next thing is the promise chaining. What
promise chaining is, if you come over here,
you can see that we are doing all the steps
through then then then then this is the
promise chaining. Okay, so first of all, we get
resolved, okay, and then it comes over here,
then we return it First of all, resolve, then
return, return, return return like that, don't
worry, we're gonna write code and explain, and I'm
gonna explain that to you. All right. So this is
a promise chaining, the error handling part is
this one. Look, this catch handler is the error
handling part when we have a reject. All right,
and the final handler I told you earlier, right,
this is the final handler handler is gonna
run whether we serve zero or 100 customers,
I mean, whether our promise gets resolved or
rejected, or I then come to your code editor
over here, delete everything except your stocks.
Variable over here, and you clear the console over
here. Okay. Now, the first thing is the absolute
first thing is we're going to create a variable
named is shop open, follow me. Let is underscore
shop underscore open, okay, equal to true.
So what this is holding is, we're asking
the question is our shop open or closed? If
it is true, we are serving ice cream. If it is
closed, we're sorry, sir, we are closed. Okay.
Now we're going to create a function, an arrow
function with the name order like this, let
order equal to brackets over here, then equal to
arrow function. Now what we're going to do is,
remember the relationship between time and
work that I told you earlier, we're going
to write time and work over here, okay, time
over here, and work over here. You can also
shift the positions you can write work first and
then time, it totally depends on you. And the next
thing is we're going to make a promise. First, we
made the order then we made the promise sir, we're
going to serve you a stream like this. Follow
me. First of all, you're going to write return,
okay, new, then capital letter P, what capital
letter p, p, r o m i s e promise like this look,
then brackets, you a little bit of space so that
you can understand what we are writing. Okay,
over here, we're going to give brackets over here
again, we're going to create a arrow function
look like this, okay? Like this. We've made
a arrow function over here. Now, press Enter.
Now, inside this bracket, we're gonna
pass two arguments resolve reject,
which means that we have how many stage
three stages, pending resolve, reject,
we're gonna write resolve, reject, we don't
need the pending. Okay? Now, right resolve,
like this resolve like this. And over here, you're
gonna write, reject, reject like this. Okay, so we
made a promise. Now it's time to run that promise.
Okay, now we have two stages, resolve and reject.
Let's write an if else statement. So right. If
is shop open, which means If a shop is open,
then we're gonna resolve it like this resolve,
which means that we're gonna serve ice cream
that our shop is open. Welcome, sir, we're gonna
serve you ice cream, how are we gonna serve our
ice cream, we're going to write this work. You
see this work over here, we're gonna write this
work over here, like this. Look, we pass the work
over here, which means that when the shop is open,
when our customer came, we're gonna say sir,
we promise that we're gonna serve ice cream.
As long as we have all the stocks and the raw
materials, then we're going to start working.
Alright, now if our shop is closed, then what will
happen we're going to write an L statement over
here, okay, curly braces. And over here, we're
going to write one reject, reject like this. And
you close it like this, I mean, the brackets
and over here, you write console of sorry,
console dot log, like this, okay. And over
here, we're going to write our, sorry, our
shop is closed, okay? Like this. So far, so good.
Now, you can see that we have formed relationship
between with just work Look, this work is over
here. But we also need to form relationship
between time also along with work. So what will
we use, we're going to use a set timeout function,
so that we can form the relationship between our
time and work. Follow along with me, okay, so
below this if statement, right, set timeout,
okay. And then brackets over here form a
arrow function like this look, okay, arrow
function like this. And then what you're
going to do is you're going to put a comma
over here, comma, we're going to pause this
time function, I mean, the time word over here,
which means that every time we need to write
the order function, we're going to place
the time and the work. Don't worry, we're
gonna write it. And then what you're gonna do is
you're going to cut this result from here, Ctrl x,
okay? And then you're going to paste it inside
this arrow function. Now what will happen is,
is going to form a seal after 1234567 we have got
seven steps. Now save this code. Let's test it.
Okay, so what is the name of our function? It's
order, okay? So come on at the very bottom over
here, right order. Okay, now brackets. Now look
at the first thing, what is it? First thing is
the time and then the work. So how you are going
to define this follow along with me. The first
thing is time. Okay, so let's look at the chart.
So this is our chart, which carries all the steps.
First thing is we need to place the order Okay,
it's gonna take two seconds, in order to write
that first of all, we're going to give the time
Okay, you're gonna write two seconds, like this to
123 2000 milliseconds and then a comma, comma like
this. And now we're going to create a small arrow
function, look at this. Okay? And then the arrow
sign. If you write the statement in a single line,
you don't have to put these curly braces, you can
just use directly like this console dot log. Okay,
first of all, we're going to select the fruit
in order to select the foot. What do you need?
backticks? What backticks like this, okay,
then dollar sign curly braces like this. So
what's the name of our stocks? There's one
Okay, stocks dot fruit. Let me check fruits,
yes, stocks, dot fruits like this. And then
we're going to pick the strawberry, okay, zero.
This has square brackets and then zero like
this. Now let's test it Ctrl S and then
the console, save it and run it like this. After
two seconds, we're going to get the result One,
two. There we go. We have struggled over here.
Now let's complete this by saying that strawberry
was selected, okay. Ctrl S, let the
console run it. One, two. There we go.
We have our strawberry was selected. I hope you
understood the relationship between the time
and work function. This was pretty simple. Now
let's start discussing about the promise chaining
which is this one over here. That then then then
then part first you have to do this, then this
then this, etc. Let's come back to the VS code
over here and at the very bottom, if we want to
work with the promise chaining you cannot have
anything between the first call of the order
and then your then handler
like this. If you want to
do promise chaining you have to do
this dot then Okay, then dot then
dot, then so on and so forth of me a spelling
mistake My bad, then you cannot have this
semicolon over here, okay, so just remove the
semicolon from there. Okay, now it's going to work
perfectly fine, you can have 100 lines of spaces
like this. And it's still going to work like this.
But for this tutorial, I'm going to have just two
spaces so that it can look very good and tidy.
Okay? So, like this, look at that. It looks
quite good. And now in order to write, I mean,
in order to given instructions said that then,
let's look at our chart. So this is the chart,
which carries the steps. What is the
next step, we need to cut the fruit,
and it's going to take two seconds. Okay,
now come back to code pen and over here,
before cutting the fruit. Let's give a call
to start the production. How do we do this,
first of all, write an arrow function like this
looked, okay, arrow sign, you can also write it
in a single line, but I'm gonna give curly braces
over here, and then you're gonna return it,
you have to return it otherwise it's not
gonna work. The first part is resolve, then
return, return, return, return, return, so on
and so forth. If you don't write the return over
there, then it's not gonna work. Okay, follow
along with me, right return over here. Okay?
Then order. What was that order the name of our
function, okay, like this look, and then you're
going to place what time first, in order to start
the production, it takes zero second 0000, comma,
and then you're going to write a function
over here, okay? arrow function like this.
Console dot log, like this. And then we're
going to write over here, production has started
production has, sorry, started. Okay, save it, and
then we're gonna clear the console. Let's run it.
So we're going to get this one after two seconds.
And this one immediately One, two. There is our
strawberry was selected and production has started
it will took two seconds, and this one took just
zero seconds. Okay, now let's write the next
step. What was the next step we need to chop
the foot? It takes two seconds, I'm in cut the
foot. Okay, let's follow the same process. Okay,
over here, you're going to write an arrow
function like this equal to then this arrow
sign curly braces right over here. What return
what was it return? Return like this. Okay, order.
We're going to write 2000 over here, which
means two seconds. Okay, it goes to like
this then console dot log. What was it? We're
gonna cut the fruit okay? The fruit was chop
sorry Ctrl S Okay. There we go. Following
this chart, let's complete our process. Okay,
next is we have to add water and
ice let's go and do it. So over here
we're going to follow the same process.
Let's actually copy this code from here Okay,
no
let's not copy the code Okay, let's just
do it manually so that you can learn it
okay follow along with me arrow function
over here okay. We there we turn
order is going to take how many seconds one
second okay 1123 Okay. Then this sign which is
the error function given curly braces over here
okay. And inside of a hearing right console
dot log. What was it backticks Okay, then dollar
sign curly braces that is because we need to
select what our liquid which is water and ice
okay stocks dot liquid come at the very bottom
over here right stocks dot liquid like this
and then zero in order to select what the water
okay and over here right and again you
write dollar sign curly basis stocks
dot liquid. And then what was it one? Okay. So
water and ice was selected like this. There we go.
And remember this this is very crucial. You
cannot have semicolons between dens okay? Remove
this semicolon from here I mistakenly wrote it
okay. space and over here we're going to write
then. brackets, arrow sign like this. curly
braces. What's the next step? Let's see. We start
the machine in one second. Okay. So right read
terror, sorry, return border square bracket. Then
first of all need to write That time,
okay, one seconds, like this arrow sign,
like this. Console dot log.
Start the machine, like this.
Next step is we need to select the
container, we're gonna select the cone,
okay? In order to do that, come here,
then. Okay, then arrow function like this
return order. It takes how many seconds? Two
seconds to select a comb. Okay. Sorry, my bag of
then the arrow function over here. curly
braces inside you're gonna write console.
log. What was it? backticks Okay, then dollar
sign curly braces over here the right stocks
dot which was it? Let's see. Top n a holder holder
and then zero because the cone is over here. Okay.
At the very bottom, holder issue LD
are like this. square bracket, zero.
Okay, then you're going to write was ice cream was
placed on this holder. Okay, so ice cream placed
on it translates to ice cream
placed on comb. Okay, next step is
select toppings. We're going to pick chocolate dot
then Okay, then this side, I mean arrow function,
return. Return order. Three seconds because
chocolate takes time to melt right? So equal to
arrow function, then console dot log. Then
inside over here backticks. Okay, when
backticks Okay, don't forget. dollar sign,
curly braces. And we're here you write stocks
dot toppings, d o p i n g s, don't forget the last
s droppings and then square brackets over here
we're gonna write zero. Chocolate was selected
like this. So we're almost done. Then we're
going to serve the ice cream serve ice cream
we're going to write dot 10. Okay, like this.
Return order, right how many seconds is gonna
take is gonna take two seconds Okay, equal to
three races. We don't need curly braces Actually,
we can write it directly ok 123 like this. Like
this equal to this sign the arrow function and
then console dot log. Okay, double quotes icecream
was served Ctrl S There we go. completed our
process now let's run our code before that
clear this console. Run it let's go strawberry
your selected production has started the food
was chopped water and ice added start the machine
ice cream place and co then where is the chocolate
there is our chocolate chocolate was selected
ice cream was served. He was the money and let
us buys the Lambo Yay. Now is now it's time
to understand the error handling part, okay,
which is this one over here the catch handler
in order to understand the catch handler,
comment a variable bottom over here, okay,
and he right? Or don't forget to remove
this technical form here. Otherwise, it's not
going to work, right dot catch like this, okay,
like this, then write an arrow
function like this, okay,
equal to curly braces like this. And over
here, right console, the log customer left
like this Ctrl S and then cleared
the console. Now this catch will
only work when our promise is rejected. I mean,
when we cannot serve ice cream to our customers,
then this sketch, then this sketch will work.
Let me show you. Okay, if you can read if you
can remember this variable at the very top over
here below the stock, which is his shop open.
It is true, let's convert it to false and let's
see what will happen theoretically theoretically,
then we're going to run this code Okay. Let's
see. We have this if statement over here.
It will run when the variable is true,
but it is false which means our shop is
closed it look at here else reject our
shop is closed. So false and then this
this code will be run first and then
at the very bottom we have the sketch,
then this line of code will run and these things
will not run this All then then then it will not
run. Let's do a test run it and let's see
what happens okay so our shop is closed
the first thing we're going to get is our
shop is closed look at this message over
here inside this reject statement look our shop
is closed and then on the way bottom look at this
is catch handler customer left We're very sorry
this left the left us look the customer left.
We're not going to make the money we can't
buy the Lambo We're very sorry. Alright then
I hope you understood this catch I mean the
error handling part with the catch handler
let's now understand this finally handler I told
you earlier that is this will run whether our
promises resolved or rejected it will run anyways.
Okay, now let's look at this example. But first,
remove this semicolon otherwise it's not gonna
work okay then dot finally like this. And inside
over here we're going to write what Tell me
arrow function take like this equal to this sign
curly braces like this. We're gonna write console
dot log like this and inside over here we're gonna
write our shop is closed. Now let's write day
ended shop is closed Okay, dead end dead shop
is closed like this Okay, let's say we remember
what state is it in our shop is closed which is
false. Okay, let's run it in this way. You can
also run it in through let's look at our shop is
closed This message is coming from this rejects
statement over here customer left is coming from
this statement over here this catch handler okay
and this day ended shop is closed it's coming
from this finally handler let's set it to true
and let's see what will actually happen without
finally handle okay Ctrl S run it to
the console and let's see what happens
okay we got this statement then this then water
nice edit then this is completion code then my
favorite part is the chocolate Yay. And then ice
cream was served day ended shop is close look
at this look look at the various day ended
shop is closed is coming from this finally
handler so what did you understand? It will
run whether our promises resolved or rejected.
And with that we finished our discussion with
promises everyone please welcome async await Yay.
So this is actually proclaim to be a better way to
write promises. Let's go and dissect async await
but first you take a break because it really
deserves a break in order to understand the async
await first of all learn to know the difference
between the promises and async await let's look
at an example. Come back to VS code I mean code
pen delete everything except our this part okay?
Keep the shop and stocks okay now in the promises
part How did we make a promise like this look?
function Let's name it order okay order like this.
Okay, no, we actually didn't write it like this My
bad we wrote it in the airway function I mean the
arrow function to let order equal to this equal to
arrow sign curly braces like this and in order to
make the promise we wrote what return new promise
return new my brand new capital letter P r o m
i s he promises like this and then inside these
brackets we wrote another arrow function like
this okay and inside here we wrote resolve reject
like this Okay. And then he said over here what we
wrote if statement Okay, then this one and inside
over here. What did we rewrite? What did we write?
We wrote the result like this, okay. Look at this
and over the else statement. What did we write?
Okay, they wrote the reject over here. Oh, my bad.
JACK like this. Okay. We wrote it like this.
This was the promise. What how do we write the
async await? Look at this blog look, right first
of all the async keyword what the async keyword
is sink. Okay, you write the function order.
Okay, this and then the curly braces. And there
we go. We made ourselves a promise. How simple
is that? But wait, the story doesn't end here.
We need to understand two more things, the try
catch handler and how to use the await keyword.
So this is the async keyword, we need to
understand the await keyword. Let's dive
in. Now let's come back to our code pen and
understand the difference between the promise
And our async await only then we're gonna
understand the try catch. Okay? Come over here and
see this if an else statement, what did we write?
How did we make the promise we made this promise
like this first of all, we load the function over
here, and then return new promise, then resolve
reject. And then we wrote The if statement, which
is if this is true, we wrote this tr, e true,
okay? Then it's going to resolve it. If it is not
true, then it is going to reject it like this.
This is how we make the promise. And then what
did we do? Okay, we comment this is like this.
Let me actually finish with the promise part. Then
we're going to come to the async JavaScript part.
I'm an async await part. This is the order right?
How did we write it? order? Okay, order. This is
our first start. And then what did you write?
dot then? Okay, dot, then dot, then. Oh, sorry,
my bad. And then what did you write? And then we
wrote dot catch, catch. TC CIT, C of I forgot my
bad ca tch catch handler and then the dot finally
handler, okay, so this will work when, what,
if our promise was resolved, this will work
when it is rejected, this will work anyways,
is still going to work even if it was resolved or
rejected. But in terms of this async await, let's
actually test it with this how this works, okay.
Don't worry about this one. Let's comment this.
We're gonna return over here. Okay, don't worry.
Comment this like this and come over here. So
first thing is if we want to declare, I mean, if
we want to work with promises in the async await.
World, then what we have to do is we have to
declare this async word before the function
I showed you a little while ago, right? And then
inside over here, you have three options. I mean,
three things to write, try, get. And finally,
what do we try to get final over here we wrote
what the if else statement, and over here
we're going to write try, catch Finally,
following the right cry over here.
Okay. Go your braces like this.
And then you're going to write the catch, okay.
And brackets over here. You write error. Okay.
curly braces. And over here you write.
Finally like this. Okay, then curly braces.
So what does this finally does it? It runs
code anyways, okay, let's write it. Okay. Don't
worry. We're going to test it. Okay. Console dot
log, runs code any way. Okay. Inside this catch
handler. I mean, let's start with the try. Okay,
let's create a fake problem. What problem fake
problem over here we're going to right away, don't
worry about a word keyword I'm going to discuss
in detail about this await keyword. Okay,
it's coming. Wait, you're right. Anyway, ABC.
So this ABC is actually pointing out to a function
which doesn't exist. I still wrote it because it's
a fake function. What function fake function
okay? So in fact, this catch handler, what we're
going to write is console, the log like this and
over here, we're gonna write ABC doesn't exist.
exist, okay? And this error is actually
written like this coma arrow. Okay.
For now, we don't need this error part, but we're
just keeping it over here as it is, we just want
to work with our try catch this console log and
this Finally, in this Finally, handler in order to
understand the main theory of the async await,
okay, so you clear the console here. As I told
you earlier, this aways ABC I mean, this ABC
part doesn't exist look at the entire code
field. Nothing exists which is named ABC right?
So in order to run this first of all you need to
provoke it like by saying order at the
very bottom over here right order okay?
My bad sorry, like this Ctrl S and let's run it
and let's see what happens there we go. We got
the message. First of all, ABC doesn't exist
because we don't have anything named ABC. Then
it then we have run scope. Anyways, look at this
the finally handler Do you remember this Finally,
from the promises, this is over here, it will
run code anyways. By the way, do you remember
this handlers this then catch finally handlers,
you can also use them inside I mean, outside the
async await system as well. Let me show you a
demo. Okay. You right at the bottom of the order
after removing that semicolon, but then like this,
okay brackets, then create a Arrow function like
this and over here you write console dot log then
write anything you wish I'm gonna write like this
My read I read I don't I cannot think anything of
good right now Ctrl F clear this run it like this.
There we go. We have got that then handler it
is pending over here. Okay? First of all we
got that error and then the final is going
to run anyways Okay, so that is over here
and then that then what will happen after our
promise is resolved is going to do this part over
here. And you can also use those then cat finally
etc. After here is the chaining part. Okay,
I hope you understood this far. Now let's do a
small test and understand that a weight keyword
let's say that I am the chef of the
restaurant, okay, just look at me.
I am the chef of the restaurant. Okay, I make ice
cream. I took the order from the customer and I'm
making ice cream okay tu tu tu tu tu my bed sorry.
Okay, so I'm making ice cream over here but I then
realized that my customer didn't tell me which
topping would he like so I have to go outside the
kitchen ask the customer sir which stuffing
topping would you like chocolate or peanut?
There he is going to give me the order. Give me
chocolate and then I have to return to the kitchen
and start working. Look how the process
is working. I am going outside which means
that the kitchen is being stopped completely
without the chef the kitchen doesn't work.
But realize this that there are other employees at
the restaurant who is working who is cleaning the
tables, cleaning the dishes, taking orders, etc.
Everything else except the kitchen is working.
This is where we use the await keyword. Let's do
a C test and understand about this await keyword
in details. Let's start now come back to corporate
Now come back to code pen and remove everything
except the stocks and the East shop open. Okay,
remove everything like this. Goodbye forever.
Okay, now what we're going to do is
we're going to create a function what
a function which run arrow function. Okay,
let, let's write toppings choice, okay.
Which will add to the customer. So which topic
would you love? Okay, it was blue my bed equal to
bracket. This sign is the arrow sign and instead
we're here we're going to make a new promise what
new promise. Okay, so return new promise like
this. And we're here we're going to write,
resolve, reject, don't worry, I'm coming on the
async await part. Okay. So equal to arrow sign
curly braces and over here what we are going to
write come on to me resolve reject. Resolving
My bad. We check like this. Okay. Now over here,
what are we going to do? We're going to create
a set timeout. Let's say that the asking
process takes how many seconds three seconds,
how many? Three seconds. Okay, in order to do
that, we're going to write set timeout, okay,
for three seconds. So write set timeout like this,
okay? And then what we have to write is Come on,
tell me arrow function. Okay, like
this. And then we're gonna set the
time, how many seconds, three seconds.
3123. All right, now inside over here,
we're going to write console dot log console. dot
log. We're here right? Which stop being you love
of my read. Like this. Remove this console. From
here. Clear. Okay, Ctrl S. Now we made a small
promise that we have to go outside the kitchen
x our customer, what would you love to have
as a topping. Now at the very bottom, what we're
going to create is function a sync function is
sync function. We're going to write what brackets
are. We also have to give it a name. We're gonna
name it kitchen. kitc HTN kitchen over here, and
then curly braces over here like this. Now follow
along with me. We're gonna write console dot
log five times A, B, C, D, E, like this, okay?
console dot log. Okay, like this.
Ctrl C, one of my red 2345. Okay, now,
we'll get right over here. Ah, don't worry. I'm
going to explain that why I wrote ABCD My bad. T.
Hey, okay. Now what we're going to do is, let me
actually explain why I wrote this ABC and all the
spots. Okay, the thing is, these are the steps
we're walking into. I mean, we're working at the
kitchen. Okay, we're making ice cream. We're
following the steps 1234 and the very mill,
we just realized which topping would our customer
love. Okay, so we have to go outside the kitchen.
What? Outside the kitchen, ask him. So what
did you love to have? So this is our kitchen,
we're inside over here, where where we're inside
this kitchen, we're working. Now we need to go
outside and come to this toppings choice, which
is the where the customer is sitting asked him.
So what would you love to have. And then once
we have got the data, we're going to come back
to our kitchen, start working and then serve
Him. In the meantime, what will happen, others
other works like cleaning the dishes, cleaning
the table, taking other customers orders will
keep running. Don't worry, I'm coming to that
part. Okay. Now what you're going to write is at
the very middle over here, you're going to write
a wait, then what the name of this function What
is this toppings choice Ctrl C, that one Ctrl
V, and then brackets, close it on. And then
what we're going to do is in order to provoke
this function, we're going to come over at the
very bottom over here, you're going to write
kitchen, what kitchen it's like this, okay?
And then we're gonna define other task, which is
happening except myself. I'm the work on the chef.
Okay, other words? What cooking? I mean, sorry,
cleaning the dishes. Cleaning the table. The other
quarters? Let's write them. Okay. Console, the
log? cleaning my bag. sealing the dishes console,
the log like this conference. I mean, this one
Ctrl C Ctrl. V, then what? Cleaning the tables?
Actually, you right doing the dishes? It
sounds good. I guess. doing dishes dishes,
cleaning the table. And then at the bottom,
we're going to write taking others order
like this. Okay. Ctrl S. Now, let me
theoretically explain you before running the Run
button that what is actually happening. Okay,
so I'm working over here. Okay, I'm making the
ice cream. And then I realized that I didn't
have the necessary direction which topping
would my customer love. So I'm physically
going outside the kitchen to ask the customer
what would you love to have, which means that this
entire process is stopped, my kitchen is stopped,
nothing is happening because the chef is outside.
And in the meantime, other work like this one
will still happen like doing the dishes, cleaning
the table, taking others orders. And once a return
to the kitchen, this to work D and E will work.
Let's run it and let's test what will happen.
Okay, look, a B, C, doing the dishes cleaning the
table taking others orders. Which topic would you
love? Oh, we didn't actually get the D and D.
That's because I actually forgot something.
I forgot to write the resolve over here. And
without reading the resolve, it's not going to
return our other tasks. Okay, so come over here on
the toppings choice Okay, or and inside over here,
you're going to write V zoolz. Like this bracket.
And inside the brackets, we're going to place this
console over here. Okay. Ctrl x, my apologies.
I actually forgot to write that part and Ctrl S
Okay, now clear this and run the code and let's
see what actually happens. Okay. Oh, I actually
have an error. I don't know why but let's check
it out. Okay, console log. Which dropping my bad.
Like go like this Ctrl S. Let's see what happens
right now if you had a console like this.
Now you can see that we have fixed our error
over here we have written the result over here
and we have replaced the console log inside this
line over here now it's gonna work perfectly
fine. Let's run the code and see what happens.
There we go. We have ABC doing the dishes,
cleaning the tables taking other orders which
dropping Do you like and then we have other works.
What is happening Let me explain again. So what is
happening look here in the kitchen, I am working
in the kitchen, where am I working in the kitchen.
So these three tasks are done. Then I remember
what topping does my customer likes. So I'm going
outside and asking him in the meantime others are
working look, other people are working over here.
If there was 100 tasks, they would have worked.
They would have been working On those tasks,
okay. So once these tasks are done in the
meantime what I have done is I have gone to
the customer action to the data returned to the
kitchen and I started working then D and E is
completed on this bottom over here you can see
that, I hope you understood the await keyword.
I hope you understood the resolve keyword.
Let's reopen our shop and welcome customers.
Okay, now come back to code and delete everything
except this one. And this one, okay, like this,
follow along with me delete goodbye. And
over here, what we're going to write is
first of all a time function because we need to
set the relationship between time and work right?
So you write a function, okay, time, and right
over here, MS, which is milliseconds, okay.
curly braces like this, we're going to
create a new promise. Okay, return, Neil.
Tom is don't worry about the async await I'm
coming to that part. Okay, capital letter P,
not small letter p, r, O, and my se. And
then you said over here we're going to write
the resolve and reject part resolve. And the
reject part, the check like this, and arrow
function, my bad arrow function over here like
this. And then the if else statement like this,
if our shop is open, is shop open look at this
is shop open, and then we're going to write what
we're going to create set timeout. Remember
this set timeout like this, and over here,
we're forming a relationship between our time and
work okay, so inside here, we're going to write
the result we are passing this result over here,
which means that we're setting the relationship
between the time and work okay. So resolve over
here and then that Ms part should be over here,
m s like this, at on the L statement, e
l s statement. So what this will do is
it will notify us when our shop is closed, I mean
when is shop open, set to false, okay, like that.
So we're gonna write reject, like this. Instead,
over here, we're gonna write console. Console,
dot log, like this. And we're going to
write, shop, my bag is closed Ctrl S. Now
we're going to write an async function named
kitchen to start our production inside there.
Okay, come at the very bottom of before that you
clean the console because it looks quite dirty.
Okay, so now you're going to write a sync, like
this function create the kitchen, okay? Okay,
it CH, E and kitchen like this curly braces, like
this over here. And then we're going to write cry,
okay, like this, then catch, like this. And
if you want, you can also write the Finally,
that's completely up to you, but I'm gonna write
it because a lot of you don't really understand
how to work with the try, catch. And finally,
I'm going to explain everything in details.
Don't worry about it. Okay. And over here, I
actually forgot to write brackets and arrow,
like this. All right. And now in order to run
this, what we have to write is at the very bottom,
we are right the kitchen, which is the trigger
kitchen, like this, okay, Ctrl S. Now let's
actually test a function to check whether if it's
working or not, so come on in this catch handler,
and we're going to write console dot log like
this. We're going to write customer left, okay,
customer, left like this and over here and
right arrow like this. And inside over here,
what we're going to write is shop is closed. Okay?
console. log. de endet. shop is closed. Okay. Now,
what are we going to write inside this
fry handler? Let's see. Okay, one by one.
If you remember this chart, the first thing
that we need to pick is the order I mean,
the fruit name. Okay, so come back
to our code pen over here. And
we're going to write console, log log,
and then backticks. Don't forget that
dollar sign curly braces like this.
And then we're going to write stocks,
like the stocks dot fruit, f r u, it s, and
then we're going to pick the strawberry zero,
or you can pick anything you wish from this list
of stocks, okay? You can pick grapes, banana, etc.
Alright, now what we're going to do is,
remember this, we have two seconds of time,
how are we gonna define the two seconds over
here? In order to define the two seconds? Do
you remember this function over here, the time
function? We're gonna utilize this look at here,
look Write a wait. And then what the
name of this function time, okay,
time over here. And then we're going to
set it to how many seconds, two seconds
to 123 2000 milliseconds means two seconds. Now
let's test that code. Okay, as our shop is open,
now it's gonna give us what resolve you can this
is going to get resolved. Okay, let's run the code
and see what happens. So after two seconds, we're
going to get this property over here. That's
because we have set it to two seconds, and they
ended shop clothes will be printed immediately
because we didn't assign any time over here. So it
is assured that that function works and there is
no problem in our function. Let's complete our
ice cream production business, following these
steps over here, okay, now what you're going to do
is come over here, you press Enter, Enter. I will
keep some space between your code so that it looks
neat and clean. And then we're gonna write console
dot log. Start the production, okay? Start the
production, it's not gonna take any time. Okay,
we're going to keep it blank for now, what if
you want to learn, but if you want, you can keep
a wait. Time. 0000 is completely up to you. But
for making you understand how the system works,
we're going to keep it 0000 so that you can know
that this thing takes zero seconds to start. Okay,
now we're gonna start, we're gonna cut the fruit,
okay, so console dot log. Got the fruit like this
is gonna take how many seconds? Two seconds?
Every time to 123 I mean two seconds. Okay,
then we have the add water and ice is going
to take one second. Let's go boys and girls.
Oh, my bad, I will do the wrong thing. Anyway, Tom
is going to take 123 like this console dot log.
And we're gonna write what water and ice backticks
dollar sign curly braces and dollar sign curly
braces was added like this and over here we're
gonna write big the water stocks dot liquid
square bracket zero. Okay, stocks dot liquid.
Then we're going to write one. There we go.
And over here, we're going to start the machine
in one second. Select the container to second.
So how do we do this? We can also copy this No
worries. Like this okay Ctrl V. First we need
what one second to start the machine and then
two seconds to select the container. So one
second is over here. And the two second part
is over here. Okay, the second part is here
and let's actually complete altogether the
toppings parse takes three seconds to serve ice
cream which takes two seconds Okay, so let's do it
like this. So these are three seconds over here.
This is our serving over here Okay,
two seconds now we're going to write
stuff start the mission okay. So console
log. Start deep machine like this.
And then console dot log. It will be our select
the container okay. backticks dollar sign curly
braces. Stops got holder? Zero it will pick
the cone. Okay. Ice cream placed on cone
ice cream placed on cone like this.
Okay, now configured log console dot log
like this. Do we need backticks? Yes, because
we need to pick that toppings. Chocolate
backticks dollar sign curly braces, stocks dot
toppings DOB imgs then zero which will pick the
chocolate was selected as the very last what we
are going to write Yes, we can serve ice cream
take the money and buy ourselves a Lambo because
why not? Come on boys and girls console a dot log.
Okay
sir, ice cream.
Let's save our code clear our console like this.
And let's run a run it and see what happens.
Maintaining time everything will run strawberry.
Oh actually forgot right strawberry was selected.
My bag was selected. Okay, clear this console.
Save it, run it again. Sequential Maintaining
time it will run look straightaway to a selected
start the production cut the fruit then this start
the machine I simulation code then after three
seconds we will have chocolate was selected
service day and shop is closed but what will
happen if we have false over here let's see okay
false which means that is going to reject it look
at here reject on the block shop is closed which
means that this else this reject this thing will
come. I mean this thing will be painted first and
then look at this catch over here. Get a better
customer left and then the final day ended shop
is closed. Let's test it. We're gonna shop is
closed customer left they ended shop is closed.
This is coming from where let me show you this is
coming from this else this reject from the time
function customer left it is coming from where
look at this is fun coming from the catch and they
ended shop is closed. This will run anyways
it is coming from this finally handler
so we successfully made ice cream today. And
along with that we have completed our tutorial.
If you liked the video, give a like share
it with a friend and feel free to subscribe
Till then Take care and I'll
see in the next video. Bye bye